[Music]
the son of a man who police say was
killed by a
7-eleven security guard is calling for
justice good evening and thanks for
joining us at 6 30 i'm brian loftis
i'm kirsten joyce his attorney says a
message needs to be sent the i-team's
vanessa murphy has this story you're
seeing
first on 8 news now
brandon martin says he was getting ready
to introduce his father to his first
grandchild we're in the process of
coming back here to come you know
let him meet the baby girl and
everything and the bad news hit
he learned his 56 year old dad thomas
martin
was shot and killed on august 26th
the accused security guard kasia
mitchell
according to this arrest report mitchell
was restricting the number of visitors
at this 7-eleven on las vegas boulevard
near craig due to covid 19.
martin became frustrated and they argued
mitchell allowed someone else in martin
pushed his way inside
they shoved each other mitchell took out
a gun and shot him
the 36-year-old woman is charged with
open murder
attorney rodolfo gonzalez is
representing brandon martin
they're considering a civil lawsuit he's
a
human who did not deserve to get shot in
the chest
for some sort of covet disagreement the
arrest report also states martin was not
armed and did not physically attack
mitchell
detectives viewed surveillance video
as a security guard you're supposed to
have the training the knowledge on how
to de-escalate
a situation not escalated dad's life
mattered
there's people that will miss him and
everything like that and like
whatever justice is like she she
murdered him in cold blood i think
you know she should she should have to
do her time martin says his father had
relocated to las vegas from hawaii
a place which was part of him he did
carry the aloha spirit with him and
you know i mean he's much going to be
missed what are you going to tell
your daughter about your dad i know he
would
light up like he lit up all the time i
would come around
and he would smile and be happy the way
he always is i know he would be the same
way
for my daughter if he got to meet her
7-elevens corporate office sent me
a statement quote our hearts are with
the victim's family
we are working with the local franchisee
to gather information
and provide local law enforcement with
any information
helpful to their investigation end quote
as for keisha mitchell detectives say
she told them
she wishes she just had a physical
altercation with martin
and did not shoot him vanessa murphy
8 news now